[Music]
okay so we have a online writing program
called self r3 and that helps people
construct the narrative of their life
that's a good way of thinking about it
and so part of the narrative of your
life is what happened to you in the past
that made you who you are now
good and bad and part of what you want
to do think about the purpose of memory
think well the purpose of memory is to
remember the past it's like no that's
wrong
the purpose of memory is so that you
take from the past what you need not to
do stupid things again in the future
right so the purpose of memory is to
learn from the past so that you can
construct the future more effectively
all right so now if you've had terrible
things happen to you in the past and you
don't understand them what that means is
that you're insufficiently prepared for
the future and that means you're going
to be in a constant state of anxiety and
stress and so if you write about your
past and you do a causal analysis of the
good and the bad things that happen to
you then that arms you more effectively
for operation in the present and the
future that and that produces an
increment in in physical health by the
way okay so that's the past authoring
program it asked you to divide your life
in two epochs and to outline the
emotionally significant events and to
essentially do a causal analysis of them
so it's like you're getting the gist of
the story of your life down you're
articulating yourself so the present
authoring program uses a personality
model to help you identify your faults
so that you can improve them and your
virtues so that you can continue to
capitalize on them it's the simplest of
the three sub programs and the future
authoring program which is the one we've
done the most research on helps you
first of all formulate a vision for your
life so the idea is okay imagine that
you're charged with your own care and
that you've determined to do a good job
of it okay and then it asks you specific
questions about your life if you could
have what you wanted three to five years
down the road what would be good for you
what do you want from your friends what
do you want from your career how are you
gonna educate yourself what
one from your family what do you want
from an intimate relationship how are
you going to handle pitfalls like drug
and alcohol use and other sorts of
temptations how are you going to take
care of yourself mentally and physically
what are you going to do with your time
outside of work that's productive and
meaningful if you could have what you
wanted and that would be good for you
what would that look like and then it
asks you to write for 15 minutes about
what your life could be like if if those
conditions were met three to five years
in the future then it asked you to do
the reverse take stock of your failings
imagine they get out of hand and things
aren't so good for you three to five
years down the road what does that look
like okay now you've established two
points something to strive for and
something to stay the hell away from and
that's maximally motivating because if
you want to be motivated to do something
you can't just be hopeful about it
you have to be hopeful about doing it
and afraid of not doing it and that way
your anxiety is behind you pushing you
forward instead of in front of you
stopping you because like imagine you
wanted to undertake a new enterprise you
might say oh my god look at all the
risks look at all the threat and that
could paralyze you but if you can say
simul taneous lee yeah fair enough
but look where I might end up if I don't
do it it's like oh well that's a whole
different issue it's like well there's
dangers ahead of you but there's dangers
behind you - so maybe it's worthwhile
taking the risk so anyways you want to
have both your negative and your
positive emotion systems working for you
then in the future authoring program you
take your positive vision and you
develop an implementable plan which
includes philosophical justifications so
one question would be all right break
your vision up into nine practical steps
develop an implementation strategy and
then articulate why if you accomplish
goal one your life would be better your
family's life would be better
your society would function better so
that you have because you need deep
reasons to keep you on track right
because otherwise your own doubts alone
do you let alone other people's
opposition you have to articulate your
rationale so that you can quell your
doubts and move forward powerfully and
so those programs that program in
particular has a very salutary effect on
people so it's it's we've we've given it
to thousands of university students now
and in business schools in particular 30
percent improvement in overall retention
[Music]